[Music] All right. Well, I think we're
going to kick off here. Um, Courtney Bowman,
thanks for taking the time to talk with me today.
Anytime. Um, excited. Yeah. I I think that what we
thought we would do today is, you know, a bit of a
telling of the saga of privacy and civil liberties
uh since the inception of Palunteer, how it's
evolved as we've expanded throughout the different
mission sets across both government and commercial
um and kind of go into some of the details and
specifically like the technology that we've had
to build to support these missions. Not just uh
the approach or the theory though that's important
as well as we'll talk about. Um, but maybe to kick
off, we can start with just a brief introduction
as to who you are. Yeah, so I'm Courtney. I I am
uh technically the global director of the privacy
and civil liberties engineering team. Um, I've
been in Palunteer since uh late 2010. I was one
one of the founding members of the PCL team. We
call it the PCL team. Um, and I came to Palunteer
from uh from Google where I've been working on
um ad uh auction design and theory. Um uh so kind
of a entirely different removed world from from
what I focus on at at Palunteer. Um but I came to
Palunteer because I was particularly interested in
the mission set. Um and I found it very intriguing
that the company was uh was focused at the time on
kind of building a formal practice around privacy
engineering. So that was enough of enticement to
draw me in. Um uh and so over the years I spent
a lot of time um uh in different parts of the
business. Um I I I started off early on in my role
in the PCL team focusing a lot on our um state and
local government work and law enforcement um
agencies and learned a lot there and I think
we'll have a chance to talk about some of those
insights. Um but over the years I've I've seen
the the the mission set of the PCL team expand
um uh and uh and branch out into different parts
of the evolving business. Um and that's been
a super cool journey to be a part of. I think
that's that's awesome. And I think the eclectic
background in some ways matches a lot of what
attracted me to Palunteer at this point almost
13 years ago. So I was doing biomedical work and
I was like contemplating whether or not to go to
grad school and you had friends who were coming
out to Silicon Valley and working at some of the
big places. But at the time, as you'll remember,
a lot of the like the other side if you weren't
working at a big tech firm was do we go and join
a consumer app startup or do maybe the precursors
to B2B SAS and it was just the sheer concentration
of smart interesting people at Palunteer who at
the time were working on a fairly narrow set of
missions but still very meaningful missions. So,
it was work in defense and intelligence. It was
anti-human trafficking work. It was anti-fraud
work. Um, it was work in global health and in
resilience. And, you know, in some ways, it's
still kind of a very simple formula where it's
like very smart people, very interesting technical
problems and very ambitious missions. And that's
what drew me here and what I think still motivates
me to this day as I work across the architecture
and product teams. Um, so yeah, I think like maybe
you alluded to it, but is it worth going into a
bit of kind of the the founding of Palunteer and
some of that early theory that informed some of
the first things we've built in the PCL space?
Yeah, I I think folks generally have some sense
of the lore of of um the the the origin story
of Palunteer that um the concept uh came out of
the founders who worked at PayPal, but um they
had some set of insights around the utility of
purely machine-driven approaches to dealing with
complex problems, especially um dealing with um
anti-fraud detection in a payment system. Um but
taking those insights and applying them to a post
911 environment where clear observations that
there were intelligence failings um and that
the intelligence community needed to reform but
it needed to reform in a way that addressed core
concerns of constituencies of the American public.
Um and so that sort of foundational insight
um kind of uh congealed into some key
commitments that drive the company forward.
Um foremost the reason why why I have a job and
I'm gainfully employed um 15 years hence is this
sort of this sort of realization that the extent
to which Palinger is going to be building powerful
technologies um that are provided to powerful
institutions we don't want that work to come at
the expense of of the protection of fundamental
rights um especially privacy and civil liberties
interests and um part of the the the difficulty of
that is that the the traditional kind of mindset
of approaching this issue set is that um there's
a there's a kind of zero sum universe in which
either you're you're uh aiming to protect security
interests of the nation or you're going to protect
privacy interests of the citizens. Um and our
observation and sort of our challenge to that
that governing ethos is that that's a false
dichotomy. Um and there are ways of um through
intelligent uh approaches to uh to product design
through thoughtful approaches to understanding the
technosocial dimensions of technology development.
There are ways of kind of breaking down that zero
sum uh set of assumptions and build towards
multiple optimization parameters. Uh and that's
kind of been one of the the driving impulses
of of our work broadly within Palunteer. And
then the central commitment of the PCL team
is to help make that real in practice. Yeah,
I think a lot of what you said about trying to
resolve those contradictions between more security
while having more privacy was the most compelling
part for a lot of people on the engineering side
as to why they joined Palunteer. You know, how
do you build a system architecture which can
maximize security and therefore like the power of
analysis. So it's not just you know uh low uh data
volume limited analysis tooling but it's I need
to do a combination of graph oriented document
processing geospatial analysis top down needle in
the haststack analysis and these all have to work
across essentially different compute frameworks
um and allow for different users with different
scopes to be able to access different information
and of course that all has to work together and
mesh with very robust security architectures that
allow you to do that analysis when you should and
under the circumstances that are allowed. So,
it's not just simple role-based access controls,
but it's having investigation authorizations
and scopes. Um, it's being able to understand
if you and I both give pieces of information that
enrich a certain object or entity, we know where
that came from. So, it's this immutable logging
framework and dealing in those tensions, I think,
was I mean, even from the earliest Gotham days, I
think the the kind of motivating force and I think
about all the resolving of contradictions that
came after in other phases of the product. And so
that's been a theme throughout I think the entire
product history of Palunteer. Yeah. And it's,
you know, I I think one of the the insights that
that I've developed over the years is that you
can be concerned about um protecting privacy in
the development of a of a powerful information
technology platform. But the extent to which you
try to do it as a bolt-on or as an afterthought,
it's going to fail. Yes. because it has to be
deeply integrated into the the core infrastructure
and the primitives of how everything else works.
Otherwise, things are going to fall through the
seams and the cracks. Absolutely. Um I'm wondering
if you have a few examples or things that stand
out from kind of this early era of use cases that
work pretty well and ones that maybe didn't work
as well but we maybe revisited later on. Um yeah
the um so we spent a lot of as I mentioned I spent
a a few of my a big chunk of my um initial period
at Palunteer focusing on um one of the the core
core areas of the business at the time which is
which was our state and local government work. Um
so primarily law enforcement agencies uh at the
state and local level uh in some fusion centers
um throughout the the western states. Um, and
this is already a complex sensitive environment
where there's there's pretty core privacy
concerns uh and and privacy interests that
motivate the work. Um, dealing with a complex
environment where there's different classes of
information that's brought together in different
environments. Uh, and this is a space where we we
kind of had to figure out how to make it work with
the the security infrastructure and the access
control model to ensure that data was limited
for specific purposes. Um, one thing that we we
really focused on in in those early years is um
some particular provisions for managing specific
classes of law enforcement information. Um, so
criminal intelligence has particular requirements
for how how it has to be acquired, how it has to
be managed over time. And then more critically,
um, how it has to be deleted after a certain
period. So for some sub sets of this data,
it has it's subject to a five-year retention
rule. Um, and if there's not a continuing nexus to
criminal suspicion or activity, at five years, the
data has to go out the door. Um, so we we spent a
lot of time kind of modeling different frameworks
for tracking that that information um uh tying it
to ongoing casework and then at the end of the
cycle making a clear determination whether it
was consistent with holding requirements
or whether it had to be deleted. So that
that figured into several different components
of how we think about the security and privacy
architecture. It's the access control model. It's
the selective revelation of data. Um it's the
uh the retention rules and then on the back end
it's sort of the tracking all those pieces from
an audit perspective to make sure that you can
have a accountable framework and say that yes we
we handled this data appropriately. Um so we we
dealt with this with a number of different data
sources but specifically we we built a kind
of module around gang intelligence which is a
particularly sensitive subclass of data. Um, and
I'm pretty proud of the work that we did in the
space. I I my you know, my uh retrospective um
sense of failure there was that we couldn't get
more traction on this. We built a really powerful
um gang intelligence module that um adhered very
rigorously and did some advanced stuff in terms
of dealing with some of the the um the security
and privacy uh and regulatory concerns, but we
could never kind of get it off the ground with
from a broad adoption perspective. So that was
that was both cool and a little bit disappointing.
Um another instance of work that we did is
around another class of sensitive information
um automatic license plate reader data. So um this
is this is an area that's been subject to a lot of
um privacy advocacy and civil society concern. um
its concern around um sort of broad collection of
publicly available information where
cars are moving and the ability to
identify that and potentially create patterns
of life analysis without criminal suspicion um
or or limiting that that that information use for
specific contexts. Um so we spent a lot of time
and effort kind of building an approach to alper
data um uh management um that uh really focused
on limiting the access and the use for specific
applications um uh enforced retention timelines
for holding the data for fixed periods. um and
then did a bunch of oversight uh capabilities to
ensure that the the system was used appropriately
and only accessed for specific purposes that a an
end user would have to certify and that became
part of the audit trail in the back end. Um and
the kind of cool successful uh outcome of this is
um the the provisions capabilities that we laid
out in the development of of of this application
of Alper uh uh capabilities um uh basically became
uh sort of the baseline for um a California state
bill. I think it was California bill 34. Like all
the provisions that we built into the system and
and publicly talked about were ultimately things
that became embedded in in state laws. the kind of
the gold standard for dealing with the sensitive
class of of law enforcement data. So, that was a
pretty cool um indication of where we were able
and I I don't want to take credit that we um you
know directly informed all of the legislation,
but I think we proved a model of how this can
be done responsibly um that other institutions
could take on board. No, for sure. And I think as
we'll talk about I think as we go through the the
other points in time that kind of uh ability to to
work with lawmakers or at least inform the process
uh is a recurring theme as well. Um when I
think about this period you know some of the the
interesting things that lasted those things that
we tried that didn't necessarily last you know
of course this was the genesis of the palunteer
ontology system right in its first incarnations.
And so when we think about the applications
in defense and intelligence, uh, you know,
it was being able to say you're not going to just
deal in rows and columns of data, but you can
actually have a semantic understanding of these
people, these events, these locations, the routes
you're taking, the information being gathered
from the field versus what came maybe uh from
from source systems. Um, and like it was it's it's
again a very ergonomic way of accessing data that
can allow analytical, operational, and technical
users to all work together. And of course there's
cross applicability to that outside of these
domains. Um and so we had some interesting
expeditions I would say in anti-moneylaundering
in work that was anti- fraud um with with the
kind of the Gotham ontology product you know I
think colloquially kind of catch the bad guy type
workflows right but fundamentally the system was
very designed for those defense and intelligence
workflows. Um though there was a precursor to
what would eventually get built later on that
was more general. Um, and I think that's that's
also true for uh some of the workflows that
actually ended up going into another product.
So, Gotham's early sibling was Metropolis,
which was a financeoriented ontology. I think
every palitarian smiles and thinks fondly in some
ways about Metropolis. Again, very interesting
in how it thought about time series data, the
domain specific ontology modeling in in in finance
workflows, but uh was once again a precursor what
would come later. And so I think you know the kind
of ethos of forward deployed engineering of trying
to see how it can work, what generalizes, what
doesn't was in full swing at this point in the
early history. Yeah. I I go off script a little
bit but like I I remember one of the my earliest
hackweek projects um with Andrew Gervin. Yes. Um,
so I I was coming out of uh uh my my former job
had been working as a quantitative analyst on on
kind of auction stuff was doing a lot with with
numbers and modeling and we the project that we
built out um was an anh helper for Gotham as a way
of kind of wedging the pieces of of um standard
um uh mathematical statistical modeling into
this ontologically based environment. Um and it it
kind of worked. we we got a little bit to we got
a useful application that was useful for for for
some um versions of of workflows, but uh I think
it was a precursor of where we needed to develop
the product down the road. Um I have my maybe I'll
end with my own Andrew Gerbin shout out as well.
My first day at Palanteer, I sat down next to
Andrew Gerbin and he had in Gotham a custom helper
he had built that showed uh the actual molecular
3D structure of some I think you know biological
precursors in this case and he was really pushing
the limits of what you could do I think with the
on the ontology and the whole kind of architecture
at the time but I was amazed and again don't
want to get ahead of ourselves but seeing what
that work was eventually able to become through
successor architectures uh was one of the most
awesome things I think that I was able kind of see
firsthand. Yeah. So maybe fast forwarding a bit
now to let's say the mid2010s. Yeah. Uh and our
expansion into the commercial sectors in earnest
and our work across Europe. Um you know this is
when GDPR was really coming into being and this
is when a lot of as we'll talk about some of the
other industry trends were kind of coalescing in
kind of the cloud and data space. I'm curious if
you can speak to kind of this period especially
from the privacy and civil liberties perspective.
Yeah, this is a really interesting period in
modern information privacy. Um, because if if you
really want to unpack what what was happening,
you you kind of have to go back to the the Snowden
revelations in 2013. Um, and this was a bit of an
earthshattering moment because it called attention
to concerns around the intelligence community
uh and access to data. Um those concerns both
identified specific issues with the intelligence
community but also started to create fractures
in the transatlantic agreements that allowed
information to be shared across uh across the
Atlantic by multinational agencies. Um and um
so that led to a kind of a breakdown with existing
infrastructure that that was in place. It allowed
the free flow of information. It led to a lot of
negotiations between the European Commission and
um the Department of of Commerce and other
regulatory agencies in in the US. um and it really
hypercharged um Europe's attempt to come up with a
kind of comprehensive consumer data protection uh
regulation that spanned all the markets and that
had this extr territorial application which meant
which means that um it applies outside of the the
continental Europe um to any commercial entity and
other types of entities that operate with respect
to European residents and citizens data. Um so
GDPR general data protection regulation um started
to go through multiple rounds of drafting in kind
of 2016 time frame. Um uh and then was sort of
solidified and and came into into force in in
2018. Um and this was a kind of pivotal moment for
us because we were following all these trends but
also on the back of the work and the development
and insights that we had built up over years and
years of working in highly sensitive environments
um in intelligence community in defense and and
law enforcement. We really had strong intuitions
about how uh how you need to structure information
technology to manage a lot of these these concerns
and risks. Um so in in the US um we have a kind
of traditional framework the fair information
practice principles which include things like
data minimization um selective revelation um
use limitation uh oversight and accountability
uh uh principles but all these things were things
that we had embedded into the core infrastructure
of Gotham and we we we kind of knew what it takes
to make this work in a reliable trustworthy sense
and we saw these developments on the other
side of the Atlantic. Um and this created a
a large opening for us to start to reach out
to and develop relationships with commercial
entities in Europe. Um and because of that um we
were able to out of the gate kind of already offer
core approaches and insights into how European
companies and transnationals that were in other
markets including the US um could could start to
address these emerging set of concerns and uh and
provisions under GDPR. Um so there was a lot of
kind of ba basic uh infrastructure that we had
built early on that was kind of critical to how
these systems um could be made to work in in in
this complex regulatory environments and it was
one of the reasons why we got so much traction in
the European marketplace uh in the mid uh 2010s.
No, I think that's that's really interesting and
it also dovtales a lot with kind of the more
industry-wide trends we're seeing across the
world. So at this point I think about you know the
2016 to 2018 eras a lot of commercial enterprises
especially were saying we're going to start moving
workloads to the cloud at least the analytics or
data ones. We now have a data strategy around
trying to centralize data, building a data lake,
building a data platform. And I think like the
the kind of motivation behind the motivation for
many were how do we basically unlock the value
of all this information or data that's trapped
in different parts of the enterprise and make
that useful for operations, make that useful for
strategy. And so this was the genesis of Foundry,
um, which is our broad-based platform, which now
underpins essentially all the workloads that we do
worldwide. And of course, Apollo underpins that.
Um but uh you know if I think about the principles
from that first period with the original Gotham
and Metropolis work that informed the design of
Foundry a lot of these same principles were once
again imperative right so if you think about the
need for uh granular security over data elements
so not just row level or column level access but
the intersection of these things um being able
to understand the derivation and flow of data
so if you're deriving new information how does
security flow with that information especially
if you're now working across big multin ational
cross functional organizations. Um the importance
of lineage. So always being able to dynamically
understand where data inputs came from, who
authored it, who ingested the data, which
version of it was touched by which people. Uh kind
of the entire who done it, but at a very specific
level of detail. Um and then all the things that
you mentioned as well on audit capabilities and
being able to understand especially as you think
about these regulatory frameworks how to post
hawk or in a dynamic way understand the usage of
information not just as the data resides in the
platform but as it's being used in applications
or different analytical tools that are built.
Yeah. Let me let me double tap um a couple of
the things that that you're calling out because
it's worth underscoring going back to this theme
of how the primitives set up the infrastructure
to be able to deal with complex regulatory
obligations. Um lineage and provenence are
especially critical from a workflow perspective
but also from from a data protection perspective.
Um and go back to the discussion around GDPR. One
of the things that GDPR introduced or reaffirmed
is a set of of rights that individuals have and
are able to assert with respect to how their
data is held and managed by um entities that uh
corporate entities and and other public public
service entities. Um but this is fundamentally a
really hard thing to do because it some examples
of data subject rights are things like um just
access to the data that that is transacted, used,
processed by by a company. but more advanced
um rights like the right to be forgotten,
the right to have my data deleted um if there's
no longer legitimate purpose for handling it. This
is the these things are actually really hard to
do in practice if you're dealing with a complex
institution that has sprawling data uh data assets
and infrastructure, lots of different workflows,
um branches in those workflows over time, um and
all sorts of endpoints that are really hard to
track. And so having the kind of infrastructure to
be able to do the lineage and provenence control
um uh is actually critical to being able to
identify where an individual's data resides
where it's been transformed um and processed over
time and to go into each of those components and
select them and either return that as a as a um as
a access request or um delete it if if there's a
deletion requirement. Absolutely. And if I think
about some of the you know customers uh that were
kind of uh instrumental at this time to us like
entering the commercial market and growing these
were companies like BP, companies like Airbus
which had you know essentially footprints across
every geography you can think oftent times with
very uh specific policies in place that were
somewhat different across regions especially even
even within Europe right and so uh these were not
just workflows around saying we're going to put
data in a place and hope that you know it's useful
someday. These were highly operational workflows.
You know it was how do we manage our oil wells or
our reservoirs? How do we ramp production on you
know the A350? Um and what's interesting and I
think what's been core to our work is you want to
enable organic crossf functional work where design
might start with a use case but then assembly
wants to chip in or you might have integrity
do a use case and then you want production to be
able to help and how do you actually facilitate
those kind of crossunctional workflows or these
collaborative realms um while adhering to all of
the policies and dictates that are there for
a reason. And so it was a really interesting
tension or trying to resolve the contradictions
again. Uh trying to build these operational tools
in the early days of Foundry with these initial
customers. Um and also making sure that like we
were meeting all the challenges, crossing all
the tees, dotting all the eyes uh when it came
to the core infrastructure and privacy asurances.
Yeah. And we we saw lots of synergies in kind of
building on the architecture across the full range
of of clients that we were expanding into both in
the commercial realm but also in the international
government realm. Right. So maybe one example um
we work with a couple of of European agencies that
focus on um customs and transportation. And so
part of their mandate is to handle passengers that
are moving in and out of uh you know the country
and understand the flow of people uh and deal
with highly sensitive records like um uh passenger
manifests uh and their their formal restrictions
on how that data can be used and managed over
time and how it can be applied for potential
investigations. is if there's cause to um to
to maybe look into a specific passenger moving
through. Um but because of the this infrastructure
that we that we had built and um one of the the
the kind of um things that I was I was poking at
earlier um the ability to be able to manage
that information, identify where it was, how
it's used and and to have an uh an architecture
in place to be able to do reliable deletion.
um we were able to enable these institutions to
carry out their responsibilities in limited use
um purpose- specific uh driven applications that
ultimately once the data is done and no longer
can be held can be um reliably deleted um to be
consistent with with a regulatory framework. Um
on the commercial side of the business at the same
time we were uh exploring a lot of work and doing
a lot of work with highly regulated industries um
like financial services uh insurance agencies and
um you know we started to see precursors of of the
um the the AI revolution that that was to come. Um
so increasingly insurance agencies um wanted to
look at ways of understanding risk information.
uh in insurance agencies are kind of the longest
stand one of the longest standing institutions
that do advanced statistical analysis to define
risk pools. Um but increasingly they're they were
looking at ways of um uh workflow improvements
and understanding the risk profile of customers
um uh and doing claims processing. Um
but already embedded in in uh in the GDPR
uh I think it's article 22 is a restriction
on automated profiling on purely automated
automated driven uh workflows. Um and so we had
to start to think about how do we enable kind of
the the or continue to enable the human in the
loop elements that allow these institutions to
um gain efficiency through the the appropriate
use of their data. Um but but also uh do it in
a way that's consistent with their regulatory
obligations and their ethical obligations to
protect the interests of the of the customers that
they serve. Yeah. Um I think when I think back to
this period I just think of an explosive amount of
product work to support all of these missions and
set objectives you talked about. So you know the
birth of the sensitive data scanner uh you know
the ability to build a build system that could
actually reconcile all these providence details.
um the checkpoints framework or the first versions
of it to be able to understand when and how access
was requested, who approved it, the entire chain
of kind of events there, right? Um and I I don't
think about I think one thing that's unique about
Palunteer always has felt unique is like these are
all intertwined engineering endeavors alongside
the core capability sets around data management,
application building, etc. These are not
separate things off to the side. And back
to a point you made early on, um, you can't do
these things as a bolt-on. Like they just won't
work at scale or across the heterogeneity
of data types if it's an afterthought. And
so I think just the creativity you can unleash
when you're faced with these problems, I think
um, is a testament to how you can end up solving
them. I think Yeah. And it's I I think it's it's
a it's a testament to the approach that we've
taken, which was very deliberate to focus on
these issues. Um so all all of the the examples
that you mentioned sensor data scanner checkpoints
um cipher uh all capabilities that were were built
out of the privacy and civil liberties engineering
team through close collaboration with um the
architecture and product uh teams um who are
managing the the broader constellation of of of
foundry capabilities. Um but because of that sort
of central awareness of these as core issues that
we have to tackle as a company, they're willing to
invest in the primitives but have a specialized
focus on why these are core concerns for us as
a company. Um we were able to kind of build
them in to to um the basic infrastructure and
make them things that could be accessible across
the broad uh broad uh suite of deployments. For
sure. So now jumping ahead to co um and thinking
about all the developments on the product side
that happened during this period of time and all
the new privacy and civil liberties engagements
and ideas and things that came to the forefront
during this period too. I'm curious if you can
talk through a bit of your recollection from this
period and maybe touch on the key points. Yeah,
it's it's a bit uh it's a bit of a dreamy period
or maybe nightmarish period to to reflect back on.
Um it seems it seems a bit like a blur, but it was
I think it was a pivotal time for us as a company
um to to gain access to, you know, we we've
always kind of prided ourselves on a willingness
to charge into the really difficult issues the
and oftentimes gray area issues where there's
lots of competing equities at stake and lots
of concerns. And this is a great example of
public health interests pitted against um concerns
from the citizenry around the management of data.
um and and highly sensitive health records
um movement information. Um thi this was
particularly fascinating um from the perspective
of somebody who's focused on on privacy concerns
um because one of the things that we
observed outside of Palunteer was this
race towards kind of whisbang uh shiny solutions
to dealing with this complex pandemic. Yes. Um,
and a specific example of this that folks
may have either kind of tried to tune out of
their memory or or may still recall is there
was a massive push in late 2020, early 2021
um to build um uh contact tracing tools um and
mobile applications that basically would help to
identify potential interactions with people who
are COVID positive. Um and the motivations make
sense. Um this is a communicable disease. You want
to understand the the the patterns of interactions
and be able to to carry out public policy based
on on that understanding. Um so in some sense
um the movement towards using devices that people
already carry with them might be a useful way of
of tracking of tracking the flow of the of the
communicable disease. Um but we and there was
a whole kind of set of of questions around how do
you build this? Is it there were competing schools
and philosophies and all of the tech industry
had sort of built up um massive task force to
to track this. Was it centralized, decentralized?
Was it Bluetooth? Was it um web- based? Um every
phone provider, every social media app was pinging
you with some version of this. Yeah. Is is there
commercial services that are already available
that could be repurposed for these applications?
Um, our intuition was to pump the brakes and
take a step back and say, "Wait a second." Um,
is this actually overengineering uh a solution
uh to a problem that can be addressed through
more fundamental means? Um and specifically as we
started to have earnest conversations with with
public health providers um and understand the data
landscape, the thing that we observe is that the
the real issues weren't around or at least the
first order issues weren't around being able to
trace movement of of the potential carriers of the
pathogen. it was really around there's a ton of
data that's already available in the public health
domain and public uh the public service provider
public health service providers have no idea how
to reconcile with that information. Um so our
approach was more to focus on information sources
that were already out there that um the the kind
of patchwork of agencies in the US state agencies
um in in Europe uh individual nation states and
and their their sub agencies and medical service
providers um to be able to put that information
in a kind of common operating picture environment
that allowed public health information uh public
health officials to make informed decisions.
Um so this COP concept, this common operating
um picture concept um was actually built on pretty
mundane data sources. It was more getting at
um what are the reported cases in a given
jurisdiction? Um do we know what the what the uh
the backlog of um PPE is in in a given hospital?
Are there enough ventilators to deal with acute
cases that are coming into the hospitals? Um these
are these are kind of basic logistics questions
that don't actually implicate too much or in some
cases any privacy interests. Yeah. But they are
core to be able to doing this uh the the kind of
public health service that needed to take place in
this time. And that was one of our key insights
that um you can actually do more with less in
some instances. It's it's more about creating the
framework to be able to do a responsible version
of integrating data and then building insights
on out of that data as opposed to let's go out
and scoop up lots of really invasive data that
potentially tracks people's movement and could be
um funneled to law enforcement agency to enforce
lockdown um or to do other nefarious things if if
that information is hacked. there's a lot more you
can do with the basic information used responsibly
in a comprehensive environment and that I think
drove a lot of our um uh public health work
during the co era for sure and when I think about
that period of time through a product lens um you
know I think about the cop and of course the work
around these common operating pictures and that
forming the basis for some deeper work we did so
both with operation warp speed with the supply
chain for vaccine production distribution and
then also with AHS protect and this was the PPE
distribution value chain, right? So, you had
all of these medical centers, hospital systems,
and there was a shortage of PPE and you had uh
the federal government trying to help adjudicate
and help route supplies to the most critical
facilities and locations across the country.
And of course, in all of those domains are lots
of privacy implications and they need to be very
careful about what information is being shared
with private entities under what circumstances and
then being able to actually do the operational
work uh to actually conduct these workflows,
right? a lot of logistics workflows, a lot of
traditional supply chain workflows, but in the
midst of simultaneous demand and supply shocks.
So what's interesting I think that developed when
I think about specific product uh evolutions
or new features was a a much more highfidelity
ability to represent scenarios and simulations in
the ontology system. So of course we could always
capture edits and you could take actions in kind
of a more atomic or you know even like kind of
like one two three kind of way but what do I do if
I need to understand the implications of routing
PPE to the northeast versus our existing plan of
doing a more uniform distribution. Um let me play
out the consequences if I then layer on two or
three additional assumptions. Um and again this is
a thing where if you want to do simulations on top
of objects and actions that are shared by these
crossf functional teams uh without compromising
on privacy or civil liberties, those things have
to be baked right into the core system primitives
themselves. Yeah. They can't be bolted on later.
Yeah. Um so so that was one set of functionality
that truly I think kind of came into being in this
period of time. A lot of the ways you can build
expressive applications in the platform. So our
workshop application builder uh some of the ways
you can author more complex functions and business
logic all kind of had to tie together again in
this nexus of do all this work as a situation
is rapidly changing without compromising on our
core principles. Yeah. Um so it was a very odd
way of working in some ways because Palunteer is
so inductive is so hivemindy with product teams
working together in every office. So not being
able to colllocate and be together in the same
way was challenging but I feel like it unlocked a
certain type of creativity in folks and like you
said even in those situations we still had forward
deployed engineers going on site and being with
customers in these agencies in these hospital
systems with these private companies as well.
So it it it limited our ability to be together
but it didn't stop us from getting to the edge
of the problem. Yeah. I I think one of the other
um kind of this maybe you know hindsight is 2020
and and having the benefit of where we are
technologically today um in the in the sort of
um AI boom um we started to see on the back
of a lot of the the applications that you were
describing um epidemiological research um uh
advanced statistical modeling to understand um
pathogen movements um uh uh development of of of
new pharmaceutical articles a kind of growing need
to build robust infrastructure to manage modeling
workflows. Yes. Um and this is this is a place
where um we started to to work uh more in earnest
uh on um the kind of full suite of capabilities
that be that should be in place to carry out
responsible AI machine learning techniques.
So mind you, this is before the large language
model um uh boom that that uh that started to
happen late 2022, early 2023. We're talking about
kind of classical machine learning techniques. Um
and a lot of what we started to to to build at
that time was the the the kind of full suite of
tools that help manage um the ML what's called
MLOps um kind of life cycle. So that includes
things like model objectives, defining what your
objectives are and then using that as a way of
doing version control and tracking so that you
can go from um validation of training data to
testing of a model in in situ to rolling out in
production, generating feedback and then feeding
that back into the next iterations of of of the
model and then all of the while creating a kind of
backend um uh uh signature or set of information
that helps track that that information um so it's
accountable to uh um to oversight authorities or
to regulators um but but more critically deals
with this really challenging issue in um the
machine learning space um of reproducibility
and in in the health space of reproducibility.
How do you actually go back and affirm that
um the model and the the modeling techniques
that you've uh you've pursued are consistent
and produce consistent results? Um and so because
of this work that we were we were able to build
out in the space we we were able in the foundry um
uh ecosystem um to build out a suite of tools that
helped advance the these types of applications.
Absolutely. And around this time there were also
a lot of policy milestones occurring as well. I'm
curious if you could talk a little bit about that.
Yeah. And actually even before the kind of COVID
period um we you know we we've had the benefit
of having a lot of um practical experiences and
understanding how advanced technologies like AI
and ML actually work in practice. Um, and this
is important because I think there's there's
more than a crack of daylight between what you
might read about as research and development
um, AI capabilities and and what it takes
for um, this type of technology to work in
complex environments where the variables are
changing. Uh, there there's constant evolution
of the data environment. Um, the use cases are
evolving and you have to deal with people um,
in real settings. Uh and that's where the kind
of intersection between the technology and public
policy really matters because if you have uh
public policy laws that are developed based on
a misinformed or underinformed perspective on
what the technology can do um you either have
you either end up with policy that just doesn't
attach to reality or is so ephemeral that it only
is useful for a certain period and then you're
you're sort of stuck with this this policy until
you can manage to get um uh the political class
to work through the next evolution. of of of the
the legislative frameworks. Um so this has been
a kind of continuous motivation for us. How do we
take the insights that we developed um as a as a
business that's embedded in the field that has a
broad swath of customers um and use that to inform
um policy makers and give them the best tools to
be able to build the best policy. So even as early
as 2018 2019 we were engaging with for example the
European Commission which at the time had put
out an early white paper on AI regulation. This
is well preceding um the current EU AI act. This
is sort of the precursor to that movement. Um we
responded to that with some practical insights
that we had developed in our own experiences.
Um we had issued a uh a publication to a Canadian
government invitation to qualify which basically
was a request to outline how Palanteer as a
company thinks about the broad landscape of
evolving AI including the ethical commitments that
companies should take and the types of model life
cycle considerations that should be built into
responsible applications of this technology. We
published a piece on this. Um we were responding
to requests for information from standards
uh bodies like NIST. Um uh providing perspectives
on on bias and development of of AI systems. Um
and all this is sort of an opportunity for us
to take the learnings that we build out in the
field and give these back to the the agencies and
institutions that have to think very seriously
about the next generation of of oversight.
Absolutely. And and one thing that I think
about kind of is dovetailing with this period
of time at least temporally is the expansion of
our defense work. So you know we talked about
how things started in Gotham kind of in core
intelligence workflows but now that you know and
especially around this period things started to
evolve significantly. So you're thinking about
kind of the entire set of interconnected workflows
from intelligence to targeting development to
strike and and other considerations around kinetic
or non-kinetic operations uh to battle damage
assessments and kind of everything in between and
around those workflows. Um and you know to make
things more complex uh you're often talking about
multistakeholder engagements uh with potentially
multi-nation collaborations happening. And so as
this defense work really becomes much more full
spectrum, I'm curious what you're thinking about
from a privacy and civil liberties perspective.
What were kind of the key things that we had to
start to take into account there? Yeah. And
and this is in the vein of pal at Palunteer,
we run towards the hard problems. Um and and
specifically for for a division of Palunteer
that is responsible for grappling with the really
complex issues. um we have to kind of roll up our
sleeves and get into the nitty-gritty of things
that may be uncomfortable topics for some people
to talk about like kinetic warfare um which has
consequential impact on on people's lives. Um,
so this was a motivation for for us the PCL
team to really start to build a practice and
discipline around how do we engage with a customer
set and with a with a product development on core
considerations around integrating um law of
armed conflict um or in Europe we refer to the
international humanitarian legal framework. Um uh
all these are sort of um uh historical uh treaties
or conventions that dictate um how uh war fighters
have to deal with the the legal and humanitarian
implications of of what they do in the field. And
it has implications to how um everyone from the
operator to the co the command line and to the to
the generals have to think about their um personal
obligations and responsibilities. Um so we started
to to look at um uh specific capabilities within
the product and and in the context of our decision
support system work um uh which is essentially
what Maven is um the Maven suite of tools is it's
providing support for war fighters to to carry out
um complex decisions um sometimes with
with lethal effect. um how do we integrate
into the different components of that of those
workflows the types of capabilities that address
international humanitarian law considerations. So
this includes things like um identifying no strike
uh list entities um that need to be factored into
targeting decisions and making that very apparent
to um to the targeteer or the war fighter um so
that they avoid any undue or unnecessary risks to
civilians or civilian infrastructure. Um that was
just a a kind of uh stepping stone into a broader
range of of areas where we saw a huge opportunity
to expand the scope of of the privacy you know
nominally privacy and civil liberties work into
a broader space of ethical engineering including
um the ethics of war fighting. Absolutely. And I
think about um a couple things you just mentioned.
One is the Maven smart system and what that
required on the technology and architecture side.
So, we're talking about uh the real integration of
kind of the full suite of imagery and full motion
video. And there's a lot of technical challenges
when it comes to being able to do sensor fusion
and integration across all those domains while
also making sure you're adhering again like
we talked about to all the dynamic lineage and
privacy systems that are inside of the platform.
Um, and then there are questions about how do you
integrate these new data modalities with what you
talked about previously with modeling objectives.
So you now have this you're trying to do entity
extraction or other types of modeling workflows
on top of all these new data sources to inform
operations. And these could be models coming from
many different vendors. These could be models
coming from many different in-house teams. But
you want to have a common backbone of how you're
doing governance and how you're tracing data to
model release to feedback. And so it's this kind
of composite system that has to work together
while allowing a lot of diverse partnerships in
in pursuit of the mission. And it's it's even
more complicated than that because you have
all these interoperability challenges with with
different agencies, different institutions across
different jurisdictions. Um, and they're
all responsible for their own protocols
uh in managing sensitive information. So, uh,
another capability that was sort of an extension
of the existing access control model was CBACK,
classificationbased access control. uh that allows
allows our platform to be able to manage the
classifications and the corresponding restrictions
on on data and intel and and work products that
come out of the system um not just within a given
uh defense agency but across um partner agencies
as they as they work on a common environment. Uh
and this is a particularly challenging uh uh
problem to to address in environments where
you know you don't have the the time to be able
to to do the the mapping in real time. You need
to rely on the system to be able to understand
what the restrictions are on a given information.
Um because they're they're real consequences
if you overexpose data uh across jurisdictions
or across different workflows. Definitely. And I
think about the fluidity that often is part and
parcel with doing these workflows in the field.
So you mentioned kind of the diversity of new
workflows have to be built on top of the core
platform as you're operating. So how do we make
sure that we're not just dealing with existing no
strike list but we can actually modify them or add
to them um if there's new intelligence about
potential civilian harm. Okay. So how do you
enable actual users who might be semi-technical
to be able to add or maybe non-technical to add in
that information in a secure way and as they do so
it is compliant with you know seback or markings
that flow with information. If I then want to use
that in a completely different tool set, how do I
make sure those controls are applied to that user
authored data the same way it would have been from
any of those sensor feeds coming in? Um, and then
if there are different or mixed permissions and
we're sharing this with a partner nation, how
does that all get reconciled? Um, these are
all the interesting, you know, plumbing problems
that are so critical to being able to do anything
effectively in the field. Yeah. All right. So, now
let's fast forward to generative AI. Yes. And, you
know, the advent of this current revolution. Yeah.
Um, you know, I think about this again through
the product lens of being the culmination of so
many investments that we've made and that we've
talked about here in this conversation. So, our
investment in the ontology system, our investment
in these granular controls across privacy and
civil liberties and data protection, uh, the way
that we thought about multimodal compute, the way
that we thought about being able to simulate and
handoff decisions between different stakeholders.
uh there was so much more to build of course but
in many ways this was the moment where a lot
of our technical investments in our platforms
had to meet their moment and I'm curious kind of
what comes to mind for you from the operational
AI perspective at large you know given we're
still in it to a degree in this moment yeah the
so our kind of general philosophical disposition
towards towards AI has been um characterized in
some circles as AI skepticism But I don't I don't
think that's quite right. I think it's something
closer to an AI realism. Um, and it it's built
on a set of ideas that we've been ruminating
over for years and years and in fact goes back
to the earliest days of of Palunteer where we
were challenging the presumptions of being able to
do these Neil and a haststack problems um through
through machines alone and having to integrate and
build on kind of human computer symbiosis to take
the best of human intuitions and the best of what
um machines can do and processing data at scale
and marry those things together in a way that's
defensible. and responsible. Um and for for years
um before AI was the the the topic dour before
large language models and generative AI came
into the four um uh Anthony Bach and I used to do
this um this this university lecture I I think had
various titles but it was we typically referred
to as like the limits of AI basically trying to
describe what AI actually is what it's not and how
it's how it can be useful and powerful and one of
the driving insights behind all of this was um AI
is a really impressive technology um divorced from
reality. If you're just talking about laboratory
settings or just in research institutions, you can
do some pretty cool parlor tricks um in closed
environments. Um but but the real kind of test,
the real uh metal where you demonstrate
where the AI works is in the operational
context and that's all the gritty challenges
of confronting technology with reality. Yes,
that's actually the the hard engineering problem.
Um, and the there's a confusion that comes out of
this and it's it's a it's a confusion that I think
is reflected in both the understanding of what
AI can do and also in the discourse around what
responsible a or ethical AI is. Um and so around
the time that that Palunteer really kind of taken
a shift and moved in the direction of of building
out AIP and and building advanced practice on
integrating generative AI capabilities. Um I had
published a blog post um about this sort of need
to reframe the problems of of e of efficacious
um AI and ethical AI. Um because really when you
get down to it and you get into the operational
realities of what makes AI works, there's actually
a pretty strong con confluence of of concerns and
considerations and practices that apply to both
ethical implementation of AI and AI that that
works. Um, and th this is sort of a grounding
set of insights that I think has driven a lot
of our more continued development work on on AI
life cycle management um, beyond classical AI
into large language model applications. Um, so
that's been kind of a a thing that I I continue
to to believe very strongly and I think has been a
driving impulse on how we within the PCL team and
I think of the broader culture of Palunteer thinks
about AI development in our products. It's once
again about resolving contradictions and you know
I think we couldn't have totally predicted though
I think some of the antecedent moments that
we saw through the Maven work and some of the
DoD work informed not in the literal architectural
sense but kind of what to expect from a how do you
operationalize you know highly capable models and
AI systems and you know the word that we say a lot
and people give us a lot of flack for sometimes
is ontology right and what's interesting is the
expressiveness in the ontology system that had
to meet its moment here with the advent of large
language models because you have these models
that are highly capable but highly divorced from
your individual context. And so if they're trained
on human language, how do you actually give them
understanding and not just essentially lexical
proficiency? And so that means in the ontology
system which started originally as maybe just
data and some amount of action modeled in a more
compartmentalized way for the initial Gotham
workflows and metropolis workflows which then
evolved an expression as we talked about through
commercial and COVID to have more elaborate ways
of defining action and simulation to now encomp
encompassing logic and ways of you can actually
embody or represent reasoning in the ontology
system like that becomes this sort of nexus of
understanding for both the human beings and the
models. And I think that was sort of the click
moment where we're like, oh, this could be that
actual shared substrate between humans and AI,
which actually does the four-fold integration of
different data, different logic, different action
and security and and data protection as well.
Um, and unless you basically have that core or
you have that way that you're transducing human
and AI action together, you're not going to find
a way our conviction to actually operationalize
these models in a way that is compliant with your
norms and actually can be measured in a normative
way against the value that you care about. Um, and
so that has been the journey with AIP and we're
still very early in it. Um, but I think about
uh all of the things that we've had to evolve in
the existing architecture in addition to all the
new stuff we've built. So all of the optimizers
or traditional models you might have brought in
in prior eras to the model op suite now can become
tools for AI, right? So in that way we're almost
like a maximalist AI company, right? Because
you're using both generative AI and traditional ML
tools and techniques. um all the data protection
frameworks that were just for users or handoff
points, checkpoints, approvals that existed among
different teams that were interdisciplinary or
required approval processes now apply to AI agents
potentially handing off actions for review prior
to being submitted. Um there's just all these
interesting symmetries and ways that things have
kind of come full circle with how we're building
these systems now for both um humans and for our
agentic friends and kind of the journey that we go
on now I think with a lot of customers is well how
do you incrementally deliver more autonomy every
day into workflows while not losing control and
while not losing a sense of what matters and what
differentiates your company. Yeah. and and to to
you know go back to the resolving contradictions
point that this concept of AIP observability is
really is really both encapsulating what it takes
for AI to work in situ um and also addressing
these normative concerns about what's the AI
doing? Can I trust it? Is it explainable? Is there
enough transparency into the system? Can I do I
have the level of accountability that I can go
back and make assertions to um to regulators or or
oversight authorities? Those are kinds of critical
capabilities that have to be built into the
workflows to be able to build the institutional
trust that make these these systems reliable. Um,
one of the other things that you know we we spent
a lot of a lot of effort kind of building out um
and is on the back of our prior work on classical
um ML testing evaluation frameworks is is the
sort of the testing evaluation validation and
maintenance components. Um because beyond the
problem of where do you make the handoff between
uh AI agents or other capabilities and other tools
in the toolkit um you have to have a a pretty
nimble framework to evaluate in the specific
context of application whether the AI tool is
doing the thing that you want it to do. Um so we
we've we've kind of built the infrastructure and
the different types of of patterns um and and
models that can be used to uh to do this sort
of discrete testing to understand the specific
risk profile of a given AI application. Um define
metrics to to assert whether you're you're doing
the thing that you need to do. uh and then kind of
have a reproducible framework so that as the model
develops over time or as the applications change
over time or the data environment changes over
time, you can go back and continually evaluate.
have to recognize um consistently that there's
a brittleleness that's built into these systems.
And this maintenance component um addresses
the long tail of application which again gets
into this point of uh you may have flashy
applications that work up front but the
the institutional trust around their their use and
application. These these normative considerations,
these societal considerations are an enduring
thing. And if there's erosion in the application
of the system um and it's not working as well as
it did at the at the time of product um product
rollout 6 months later you have a real problem
um you have a erosion of trust problem. So all
these these features are kind of core components
of what AIP needs to have in place in order to
uh to work and I think this is again um if I think
back to our early days and what mirrors to now
it's the ambition of that problem that I think
attracts a lot of people and is very motivating
to our product teams um and and to people who
are looking at Palunteer and wanting to work
with us and if I think about some of the use
case examples that kind of dovetail off of what
you're saying I think about you know a couple
hospital systems that are trying to integrate
agents into critical workflows like nurse
scheduling or capacity management or patient
care. And of course, you're not going to flip
a bit and just have uh an agent do stuff there.
Nobody would think that's acceptable. Nobody would
find that useful. Um, but can you have a system,
a shared harness where the master nurse schedulers
who are experts at this can have AI start to be
incrementally useful for maybe one part of their
triage workflow and then maybe start to propose
possible schedules or changes that could make
their lives easier so they're not doing as much
manual work and they can focus on amplifying their
human expertise. Right? We talk about giving human
beings superpowers through the software. Um, and I
think about, you know, recruiting workflows where
it's important to try to automate what you can,
but it's really important to make sure that bias
and unintended factors are also controlled as
you're doing. It's that observability point is
critical to even getting to the starting line
with those workflows. Um, and I think in each
of these cases, it looks much more like turning
the wrench incrementally towards an epic outcome
and I think much faster than people think than it
is some sort of magic genie that, like you said,
could give a whole new meaning to the words model
drift if it starts to do things you don't expect.
and and all along the way it's it's about kind of
rein building and reinforcing the trust cycles.
So this is again why the the testing frameworks
are so important because if you can incrementally
demonstrate that the additional capabilities
that you're offering are reliable capabilities
not just from the perspective of meeting core
metrics or benchmarks but more critically from
producing operational outcomes that people can
see are useful and are consistent with their
kind of analog expectations of of how a workflow
should be carried out. That's how you get people
more comfortable with a system with its with its
reliability and um thinking in a mode of of how
does how do they kind of advance their their own
uh their own responsibilities and build out more
capacity. And I think maybe just one final note
on that is that that what you just described is
a very compelling technical challenge because
we've talked about data lineage but now really
it's decision lineage. It's how do I trace every
piece of information that informed every piece of
the ontology that was used by these models, handed
off to a user, potentially used to inform a task
and then maybe resulted in a piece of feedback and
you know that's a very interconnected system which
at runtime could be doing things very differently
between executions. Um and so in some ways it
it feels like a continuous journey and in other
ways it's just much more ambitious than anything
we could have probably imagined in the early
days. Yeah. And as that ambition expands and
we see larger adoption and we see institutions
take on more and more advanced applications of
of AI technologies while at the same time
there's increasingly complex and rigorous
um governance and and regulatory environments.
Um there's a need to provide the the the kind
of framework for governance of all those
applications. This is why we we built and
have continue continued to build out capabilities
around what we call the AI use case manager. Um
so it's basically kind of a governance tool that
helps um track all these complex applications,
the multistakeholder environment against the
specific regulatory or oversight um requirements
uh and and be able over time to to identify
the consistency of the AI applications and the
the changing models and uh different contexts
in which they're applied against all of these
uh these these requirements. Um, so that's been
a cool thing to uh to demonstrate and has gotten
a lot of traction across both our government and
commercial uh businesses. All right. So maybe just
to wrap up, Courtney, I thought we would maybe
close out with some things we're excited about,
some forthcoming things that people should look
out for. Y um I think maybe one thing I can share
is on the developer tool chain side, it's really
exciting times. So, you know, we went from not
really having any developer conferences or much
of a developer presence to doing three developer
conferences in under a year. And I think it's
been really explosive inbound demand, you know,
with our startup cohorts and with builders inside
of companies building their AI enabled products
and services on top of Foundry and AIP. And so
I think about the ontology SDK and everything
that's forthcoming there. Pound your MCP so you
can build a systems in a secure way. um and all
the capabilities that we're building into the
core platforms from autopilot uh to all the
new observability tooling that's really going to
make it I think the equivalent of what hyperscaler
building was maybe in the mid2010s for kind of
normative builders for AI builders I think in this
next generation so stay tuned for a bunch on that
front but I'm curious what's on your mind yeah
so lots of things that that we're focused on on
within the PCL team but kind of picking up on some
of the things we've been talking about the space
that everyone's interested in in uh AIP land. Um
uh I I talked about the AI use case manager and
there's just a huge open space of of green field
um uh development work that we're we're focused
on uh in the months and potentially years ahead.
Um so near-term we're super excited about again
going back to the primitives, how do we take the
concept of ontology and build that into the
governance framework of of AI applications?
um because they're consistent concepts that
people have to think about. They're concepts
that relate to the regulatory policy landscape
and all that can be translated into applications
um of of AI technology in uh in the platform uh
and the governance of of those uh AI components.
Um so that's super cool and then sort of building
on that um we can with the ontology create more
governance tools for builders within the
platform. So ho how do you take consistent
concepts or templatized um uh model oversight
paradigms and then translate that into tools
that builders in the platform can use to make
sure that they're consistent with or their
institutions are consistent with their regulatory
obligations and then even building more on top
of that is what are the potential applications of
generative AI for AI governance within the AI use
case manager. Are there ways that we can draw upon
agentic components to be able to help facilitate
some of the governance requirements?
Um, and and the the key insight here,
the thing that we're constantly being mindful
of is we don't want to overstep in terms of uh
in terms of assuming too much capability.
Um but there are instances where there's
repeated patterns and learnings that can be
translated into agentic applications that can
help facilitate uh institutions and over oversight
authorities abilities to manage their AI use cases
responsibly. Um so those areas of development
are super cool and and uh we're excited to to
build them out. So maybe it's fair to say our
latest contradiction we're tackling is more AI
enabled building or more building in general
ways to build with better governance. Yeah,
I think that's right. Awesome. Well, I can't
think of a better way to end it than that. So,
thank you, Courtney, for taking the time to
chat today. No, it's been super fun. Thanks,